jusqu'à ce que ça transperce.
La raison pour laquelle,
tout le monde regardait fixement cet instrument ce jour-là
c'est que le chirurgien devait faire très attention
de ne pas faire pénétrer l'instrument trop loin
en perforant des vaisseaux sanguins ou des organes.
Ce problème ne devrait pas vous être étranger
parce que vous l'avez sûrement déjà rencontré ailleurs.
(Rires)
Ça vous dit quelque chose ?
(Applaudissements)
Vous saviez que, à tout instant,
la paille pouvait percer un trou
sans savoir si ça allait traverser de l'autre côté jusqu'à votre main,
ou si ça allait mettre du jus partout.
Vous étiez terrifiés, n'est-ce pas ?
À chaque fois que vous faisiez ça,
vous observiez le même phénomène de physique
que j'observais ce jour-là dans la salle d'opération.
Il s'avère que c'est un vrai problème.
En 2003, l'Agence américaine des produits alimentaires et médicamenteux
a affirmé que l'incision au trocart
est l'étape la plus dangereuse en chirurgie mini-invasive.
Et puis en 2009, un journal a déclaré
que les trocarts étaient responsables de plus de la moitié
des complications majeures en chirurgie laparoscopique
Et, soit dit en passant,
tout ça n'a pas changé depuis 25 ans.
Quand j'ai entamé mes études supérieures,
je voulais travailler sur ce sujet.
J'essayais d'expliquer à un de mes amis
ce à quoi je consacrais tout mon temps.
Je lui ai dit :
« c'est comme quand tu perces un trou dans un mur
pour accrocher quelque chose dans ton appartement.
Il y a un moment où la perceuse perfore le mur
et c'est là que transperce, Pas vrai ? »
Il m'a regardé et m'a dit :
« C'est comme quand on perce un trou dans un crâne ? »
Je lui ai répondu : « Pardon ? » (Rires)
Donc j'ai fait des recherches et
on perce bien dans les crânes des gens.
Plein d’opérations neurochirurgicales
commencent par une incision faite à la perceuse dans le crâne.
Si le chirurgien ne fait pas attention,
il peut enfoncer la mèche dans le cerveau.
C'est à ce moment que j'ai commencé à penser :
« D'accord, il y a la trépanation, la laparoscopie,
pourquoi pas d'autres domaines en médecine ? »
Quand êtes-vous allés chez le docteur pour la dernière fois
sans vous être fait piquer ?
La réalité
est qu'en médecine, on vous perce pour tout.
Voici quelques procédures
qui nécessitent à un certain point la perforation d'un tissu.
Prenons trois exemples :
la laparoscopie, l'anesthésie péridurale et la trépanation.
Ces procédures sont responsables de plus de 30 000 complications
chaque année rien qu'aux États-Unis.
C'est un problème qui mérite d'être résolu.
Examinons de plus près certains des instruments
utilisés dans ce type d'opérations.
Voici une aiguille de péridurale.
qui sert à transpercer les ligaments de la colonne vertébrale
pour anesthésier les femmes qui accouchent.
Voici des instruments dont on se sert
lors d'une biopsie de la moelle osseuse
pour percer l'os et prélever un peu de moelle osseuse ou d'os.
Voici une baïonnette de la guerre de sécession.
(Rires)
Si je vous avais dit que c'était un instrument chirurgical de perçage,
vous m'auriez sans doute cru.
Parce que c'est quoi la différence ?
Et donc, plus je faisais de recherches,
plus j'étais persuadé
qu'il doit y avoir une meilleure méthode
Selon moi, la clé du problème,
c'est que tous ces instruments chirurgicaux
fonctionnent tous selon les mêmes principes de physique.
Quels sont ces principes ?
Revenons au mur et à la perceuse.
Si on applique une force sur un mur,
selon Newton, le mur appliquera une force égale
dans le sens contraire.
Lorsqu'on perce un trou dans le mur,
les deux forces s'annulent.
Mais il y a un moment où
la perceuse traverse le mur.
Alors, le mur ne présente plus aucune résistance.
Mais votre cerveau n'a pas encore réagi à ce changement.
Pendant une milliseconde
ou le temps que vous réagissiez, vous continuez à pousser.
Le déséquilibre des forces provoque une accélération
et ça s'enfonce d'un coup.
Et si, au moment exact du perçage,
on pouvait retirer la pointe de l'instrument
pour éviter cette accélération ?
C'est sur cette question que je me suis penché.
Imaginez un instrument avec un bout pointu
servant à percer un tissu.
Quelle serait la façon la plus simple de retirer sa pointe ?
J'ai pensé à un ressort.
En l'étirant, on avance la pointe de l'instrument
pour qu'elle puisse percer le tissu.
Le ressort tend à vouloir retirer la pointe.
Comment garder la pointe à sa place
jusqu'au moment du perçage ?
J'ai utilisé ce mécanisme.
Quand on presse la pointe de l'instrument contre le tissu,
le mécanisme s'élargit vers l'extérieur et appuie contre les parois.
La friction générée verrouille le mécanisme
et empêche le ressort de retirer la pointe
Au moment précis de la perçage,
le tissu ne retient plus la pointe.
Alors, le mécanisme se décoince et le ressort retire la pointe.
Laissez-moi vous le montrer au ralenti
à près de 2 000 images par seconde.
Remarquez bien la pointe au bas de l'image.
Elle est sur le point de percer le tissu.
Vous voyez qu'au moment du perçage,
juste là ,
le mécanisme se décoince et retire la pointe.
Je veux vous remontrer la vidéo d'un peu plus près.
Vous allez voir la pointe
Dès qu'elle perce la membrane de caoutchouc,
elle disparaît dans sa gaine blanche.
Juste là !
La pointe est retirée 4 centièmes de seconde après le perçage.
Puisque ce dispositif est conçu pour prendre en compte tout type de perçage
que ce soit la trépanation,
la laparoscopie ou toute autre opération,
il est possible de l'appliquer à toutes ces disciplines médicales
et à différentes échelles de longueur.
Mais ça n'a pas toujours ressemblé à ça.
Ça, c'était mon premier prototype.
Oui, ce sont des bâtonnets de sucettes (Rires)
avec un élastique en haut.
J'ai mis 30 minutes environ pour faire ça, mais ça a marché.
Et c'était la preuve que mon idée marchait.
Ça a justifié de dédier les deux années suivantes à ce projet.
J'ai travaillé là-dessus parce que ce problème me passionnait.
Parfois, j'en n'en dormais pas.
Mais je pense que ça devrait vous fasciner aussi,
parce qu'on a vu que le perçage est utilisé partout.
Donc à un moment ou un autre, ça va devenir votre problème.
Ce premier jour, dans la salle d'opération
je n'aurais jamais imaginé être un jour à l'autre bout du trocart.
Mais l'année dernière,
j'ai eu une appendicite pendant mes vacances en Grèce.
À l'hôpital à Athènes,
le chirurgien m'a dit
qu'il allait faire une laparoscopie.
Il allait faire de petites incisions pour enlever mon appendice
il parlait de ce à quoi je devais m'attendre pour mon rétablissement
et ce qui allait se passer.
Il a dit : « Des questions ? » et j'ai répondu : « Une seule, docteur.
Quel genre de trocart allez-vous utiliser ? »
Ma citation préférée sur la laparoscopie,
vient du Docteur H.C Jacobaeus :
« C'est le perçage-même qui comporte des risques ».
C'est ma citation préférée parce que H.C. Jacobaeus
a été le premier à pratiquer une laparoscopie sur des êtres humains
et il a écrit ça en 1912.
Ça fait près de 100 ans que ce problème affecte, voire tue des gens.
On pourrait penser que pour chaque problème sérieux,
il y a une équipe d'experts qui travaillent jour et nuit pour le résoudre.
La vérité, c'est que c'est loin d'être le cas.
Nous devons identifier ces problèmes
et trouver des moyens de les résoudre.
Donc si vous tombez sur un problème qui vous taraude,
acceptez de ne pas en dormir la nuit.
Laissez-vous prendre par la passion
parce qu'il y a tellement de vies à sauver.
(Applaudissements)